bonsoir avec nous en direct sur arte
france avant d'aborder la question des
municipal qui vous intéressent
particulièrement
un petit décryptage de l'actualité avec
toujours la réforme des retraites qui
occupent le devant de la scène dans un
climat que l'on sait extrêmement tendue
vastes coupures d'électricité ce matin
encore dans le sud de paris revendiquer
clairement par la cgt énergie qui assume
est-ce que vous cautionnez vous ce genre
d'action pour se faire entendre alors je
ne le cautionne pas et je le condamne
même à ce que je pense le droit de grève
est un droit constitutionnel en revanche
il est interdit de bloquer soit le
service public des transports soit le
service public de l'eau de l'électricité
du gaz et donc il est inacceptable que
des syndicats où certains membres des
syndicats des tournelles usage du droit
de grève au profit de ce qui semble être
une attaque en réalité à la liberté de
chacun normalement je le condamne très
fermement
alors autre bataille dans la bataille
les syndicats entre deux intrusions
siège de la cgt à cfdt pardon
revendiquez toujours par la cgt énergie
cette pression exercée d'un syndicat sur
un autre parce qu'on n'est pas d'accord
là encore une une réaction vous
comprenez que les cégétistes soit à bout
de nerfs aujourd'hui toute chose
comprendre la colère des uns et les
autres n'ont pas le temps on ne peut
jamais excuser la violence et
l'intrusion chez un autre syndicat la
liberté syndicale est elle aussi une
liberté fondamentale de notre république
liberté syndicale ça veut dire liberté
de tous les syndicats et il est
inacceptable que certains membres d'un
syndicat parce que je veux croire que la
majorité des membres de la cgt ne sont
pas dans cette situation puisse s'en
prendre à des salariés d'assad était
donc j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
témoigner ma solidarité aux salariés et
aux militants de la cfdt je leur fais ce
soir parce que je pense que c'est
inacceptable qu'on s'en prenne à eux
alors en tout cas cette bataille
finalement peu ça a été le cas en tout
cas pour l'assurance chômage bénéficier
au gouvernement qui fait passer une
réforme qui pourtant n'est pas populaire
majoritairement auprès des français
c'est c'est l'analyse que vous en faites
à quel prix alors déjà la réforme n'est
pas encore passé le prénom république
avait annoncé la couleur pour la
campagne présidentielle il avait dit
qu'il voulait une réforme des retraites
dont il a un mandat électoral pour la
mettre en oeuvre ce que l'on peut
regretter c'est que la méthode qui était
adaptée a conduit à sa tombe de blocage
et de tensions dans le pays
le président la république et son
gouvernement ont mis du temps mais ils
ont fini par abandonner ou reporter la
mesure de l'âge pivot qui était celle
cristalliser les colères dans le secteur
privé et reste le système dit par points
qui conduit à l'universalisation du
système de retraites
donc cette réforme peut aller au bout ce
n'est pas encore fait souhaitons que
maintenant on retrouve surtout le calme
et l'apaisement parce que vous savez
pour les usagers notamment les
franciliens les usagers des transports
publics qu'ils soient le métro la sncf
pour tous les franciliens mais aussi
pour tous les français vraiment il ya un
ras-le-bol généralisé moi je sens les
gens tendu épuisé fatigué donc je leur
témoigne masquer les réalités parce que
vraiment c'est très fatigant pour les
gens c'est grève qui dure qui dure qui
dure
alors c'est vrai que on en reçoit
évidemment comme chaque chaîne de
télévision sur ce plateau qui nous
disent oui mais la violence elle est du
côté du gouvernement qui veut nous
imposer des lois dont on ne veut pas
qu'ils donnent aux plus riches il ya une
vraie tension est ce qu'elle vous semble
inédite dans le pays on a quand même vu
un président de la république cibler ce
week-end alors qu'il était au théâtre
est ce que ça vous inquiète ce climat
extrêmement tendu
oui je ça m'inquiète bien sûr puisqu'il
ya une tension quand même assez inédite
dans l'histoire la 5ème république
l'année dernière le mouvement d'idées
gilet jaune avec quand même de la
violence de la casse beaucoup de blessés
des morts est cette année de nouveau
de la casse des violences un appel
contre l'autorité une remise en cause de
cette autorité
or je pense que notre pays on a besoin
d'ordre d'autorité mais aussi de
sécurité et surtout de calme et
d'apaisement j'ai envie que je pense que
les gens ont envie de sortir de cette
phase extrêmement douloureuse ils
comprennent qu'on ait besoin de faire
des réformes
en revanche mais s'interroge sur les
blocages qui sont suscitées par celle ci
ils ne savent pas s'ils doivent accusé
le gouvernement accuse les syndicats
je les comprends parce que moi même
souvent je me demande qui est le vrai
responsable de tout cela mais comme tout
le monde j'ai envie qu'on retrouve du
calme et de l'apaisement et de l'ordre à
nicolas sarkozy on l'entend dès hier se
vanter un peu avec humour voilà d'avoir
fait passer plein de réformes dans le
calme vous avez été très proche un
responsable de la communication de
françois hollande est ce que cette
tension pour vous elle est
particulièrement lié à ce gouvernement
d'emmanuel macro que vous connaissez
bien vous avez été à l'école ensemble
est ce que je sais ce gouvernement là on
sait un cumul de choses et je crois que
tout gouvernement à son moment de
cristallisation des colères c'est arrivé
sous chirac et dont le deuxième mandat
avec le cpe c'était sous le premier
mandat avec les grèves de 95
c'était aussi violent la dame est
justement à chaque fois il y avait un
seul rendez vous là déjà il y en a eu
deux on a eu la cristallisation l'année
dernière qui était quand même très
violente et cette année de nouveau donc
c'est assez inédit sous la vème
république et ses cristallisation d'un
côté on peut se dire que c'est parce
qu'il ya une volonté réformatrice
partiellement puissante du programme
public et de l'autre côté on peut quand
même s'interroger sur la méthode et
peut-être aussi sur l'état du pays
la france me donne parfois le sentiment
d'être un corps dont la peau a été
retiré à vif et sur lequel on ne peut
pas pratiquer les thérapies de choc il
faut faire attention il faut faire
attention
oui il faut réformer mais il faut le
faire avec intelligence et recherche du
consensus sans forcément à mener un
combat du bien contre le mal
alors emmanuel macron tentent de parler
de bonnes nouvelles économiques hier
d'une france qui avant avance grâce aux
réformes il exprime
hier c'était sa frustration face à cette
période dit il qu'on voudrait morose il
y avoue
selon vous dans la parole présidentielle
je crois que la situation économique est
meilleure qu'il ya quelques années il
faut le reconnaître les efforts qui ont
été accomplis par nicolas sarkozy pour
sortir de la crise de 2008 amplifiées
par françois hollande quand il à
redresser le pays bénéficie aujourd'hui
allemagne maton qui a apporté sa propre
touche personnelle d'attractivité
d'indépendance et entrepreneuriat tant
mieux si la france va mieux et c'est une
vraie bonne nouvelle
maintenant il faut que ça dure parce
qu'on sent aussi qu'il ya des signes
inquiétants du point de vue de la
conjoncture économique mondiale
en revanche je me méfie toujours quand
on est chef de l'état commence à dire
que le peuple est trop ceci trop cela je
pense que le rôle du chef de l'état
c'est pas d'être un prof de
développement personnel dans lequel on
accuserait les gens d'avoir des troodon
de negative leurs hôtes du printemps
république c'est de travailler d'être
tous les jours à la tâche mais pas de le
juger son peuple alors parmi les
tensions on le voit illustration en tout
cas de ces tensions c'est ce sont ces
violences de part et d'autre sur le
terrain les accusations de violences
policières de la part des manifestants à
lui un ami de l'intérieur et même un
président de la république a rappelé un
petit peu alors d'appeler à plus de
déontologie les partis politiques ps la
france insoumise rn qui appelle à la
définition du préfet de police de paris
vous êtes concerné par paris est ce que
vous partagez cet appel à la démission
du préfet l'allemand vous savez moi j'ai
travaillé très longtemps pour l'état je
travaille aussi pour le maire de paris
bertrand delanoë j'ai appris quelque
chose c'est qu'il ne faut jamais appelé
à la démission des hauts responsables
publics parce qu'ils font leur maximum
pour bien faire leur travail et on a
besoin d'eux à leur juste place
moi je n'ai pas d'appréciation spurs et
aux arbres certainement je n'ai pas
d'appréciation personnelle a porté sur
le travail du pavé le polisseur en
revanche ce que j'observe c'est que
aujourd'hui on l'a vu l'année dernière
il ya eu des problèmes dans le maintien
de l'ordre de nombreux blessés des
moments où on a le sentiment que les
forces de l'ordre étaient débordés et
cette année il ya des images qui nous
ont tous choqués il ya même eu un mort
vous savez qu'à paris cédric joue via
est mort à la suite d'un contrôle
d'identité lorsqu'il en dehors d'une
manifestation à côté de la tour eiffel
ça c'est quand même totalement inédit
dans les dernières années que quelqu'un
meurt à la suite d'un contrôle
d'identité alors la justice nous
permettra de savoir ce qui s'est passé
mais le sentiment que l'on a
collectivement c'est que quand même on a
une police qui fait son maximum qui fait
d'eux le fait dans des conditions
difficiles mais parfois il ya des abus
laisser aller et peut-être un manque de
cadres et d'autorité moi je ne vise
jamais les policiers individuellement
même si parfois ils peuvent commettre
des fautes en revanche je pense que
l'encadrement comme dans l'armée doit
être fort puissant pour justement éviter
ce genre de mode allemand pour pas que
les policiers les gendarmes se sentent
tout permis
les agents justement c'est vrai que je
sois bien n'ont pas été suspendues au
grand désarroi de la famille pour moi
c'est incompréhensible
c'est incompréhensible que des agents de
police qui font l'objet d'une procédure
judiciaire à l'heure actuelle puisqu'il
ya eu l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire pour des faits extrêmement
graves
alors quelqu'un qui est mort n'est pas
été suspendus ils ont droit bien
évidemment à la présomption d'innocence
mais comment est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils puissent aujourd'hui exercer
leurs fonctions
avec une telle procédure judiciaire qui
a été enclenché honnêtement je ne trouve
pas ça dit tout comme je n'ai pas trouvé
digne que le ministre l'intérieur mètres
près de deux semaines pour recevoir la
famille de cédric joue via donc une
bombe ne leur ténois une nouvelle fois
ma solidarité pas ce qui est arrivé
était épouvantable
on en vient aux municipales vous êtes
candidat
on l'a dit alors hier sur france info
vous dénonciez une grande division enfin
ça n'a échappé à personne est appelée à
m je cite les égos de côté vous vous
adressiez à qui précisément une siro
croit deviner évidemment non mais qu'on
prend un peu de recul et qu'on regarde
les enquêtes d'opinion qu'il faut
toujours prendre avec un peu de pression
parce que ces 17 élections que laquelle
la compagnie a juste de commencer
véritablement et ça joue au niveau des
arrondissements
qu'est ce qu'on regarde regarde que sa
crosse qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est que
50% des électeurs parisiens sont contre
ce duel dati hidalgo qu'on nous promet
ils sont sur une zone centrale qui est
progressiste démocrate écologiste mais
qui est extrêmement divisé
pourquoi parce qu'on a le sentiment
qu'il ya des candidats qui se font une
compétition essentiellement sur des
questions
au titre cédric villani bas niveau
personnellement j'ai peut-être même
suivi pourtant j'ai discuté souvent avec
la navette aux tchèques sont pas compris
ce qui les sépare et idéologiquement
j'ai toujours pas compris pourquoi il
n'avait pas réussi à se mettre d'accord
on a l'impression vous savez d'être dans
une cour d'école dans le mec il y en a
un qui a piqué son quatre heures à
l'autre qui veut pas lui rendre est l'un
et l'autre ont oublié la raison de leurs
divisions
ou alors c'est un mauvais remake de
l'album d'astérix la zizanie ou en fait
les gens se font la guerre en permanence
et au final ce sont qui les citoyens qui
tringle parce qu on pourrait en rire et
j'en ai souri avec vous aujourd'hui
mais en réalité c'est pas drôle pourquoi
parce que quand il ya 50 % des parisiens
qui sont pour le changement pour la
création d'une alternative
le fait qu'ils aient cette division
extrêmes ce n'est pas normal ce n'est
pas souhaitable et c'est pour cela
qu'aujourd'hui il faut faire halte au
feu et ne pas se tromper de combat
le vrai combat on doit le porter contre
la maire sortante qui elle a failli dans
ses missions de maire de paris
gaspard grand air justement vous ne
trouvez pas enfin vous avez l'habitude
de la politique vous semblez très étonné
par cette guerre d'ego vous voilà
pourquoi l'un se retirerait en faveur de
l'autre les hommes politiques nous ont
habitués à aller jusqu'au bout en
général dans leur vie alors il vous a
échappé que pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 et mieux macron
avait appelé à faire de la politique
autrement
je trouve que moi j'ai voté pour le
maquereau au premier taux et au deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle parce
que ceux présents avec lui que je
connais bien depuis longtemps je m'ai
fait confiance sur cette possible de
renouvellement démocratique et aqua
j'assiste j'assiste à la caricature de
ce qu'il ya de pire dans la vie
politique traditionnelle ou lol ou dans
la vieille politique comme il disait
c'est à dire des querelles d'ego des
scissions internes à des partis et je
vous pourrez moment idoine
je pourrais m'en manquait je pourrais
m'en réjouir mais ce que j'observe c'est
qu'on fait ça au dessus le débat
démocratique à paris et alors peut
parier comme une ville importante en
france il n'y a pas que paris vient
évidemment on n'a pas le droit à ce beau
débat sur l'avenir de la ville je ne
sais pas à qui doit s'adresser mesnel
macron est-ce que c'est à benjamin
gayraud ou ce que cédric villani
je ne sais pas si l'un doit se retirer
au profit de l'autre mais en réalité
aujourd'hui ce que j'observe c'est
qu'ils sont en train de se tirer vers le
front tous les deux ils sont en train de
couler à pic dans la seine et ils
n'auront jamais s'en relever résultat la
maire de paris risque d'être réélu
ce qui de mon point de vue serait une
catastrophe donc vraiment que le prénom
la république que le premier ministre
je ne sais pas qui à la république en
marche les mettent autour d'une table
moi je suis prêt à faire
monsieur bons offices casques bleus si
c'est nécessaire mais honnêtement qu'ils
arrivent à se retrouver
et peut-être aussi on associe aux david
belliard qui lui aussi veut s'affranchir
de même de la majorité municipale qui a
un vrai projet aux progressistes et
écologistes écologistes et progressiste
et qui peut faire avancer cette ville
justement david bellion isabelle saporta
ancienne chroniqueuse à un vers celle
qu'on connaît avait annoncé le 20 août
faire équipe avec vous un 20 août
dernier elle envisage de rejoindre david
belliard qui est crédité d'ailleurs de
1% si je n'en peux plus
pas mal c'est qu'on a pas bien avec nous
je cherchais sur malysz pardonnez moi
une réaction justement sur voilà son
bonnet c'est un peu comme une trahison 1
voilà un parachutage un petit peu utile
vous savez dans la vie il ya la
politique mais il ya surtout l'amitié et
isabelle saporta c'est une personnalité
exceptionnelle que j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer cette année c'est quelqu'un
de convaincu de courageux avec des
convictions extrêmement sincère elle
mais a dit cet après-midi gaspard je
suis toujours avec toi je veux toujours
qu'on avance ensemble bien évidemment je
veux construire cette alliance pour le
climat comme toi je veux travailler à un
grand rassemblement
elle m'a dit que les informations du
monde qui était révélée par le monde
était fausse et les a démenties
d'ailleurs publiquement donc vous savez
j'ai confiance en elle et je n'ai pas de
raison de ne pas la croire
dernière question la circulaire castaner
un des élus à l'air qui ont saisi le
conseil d'état
une manoeuvre de la part de la
république en marche comme le dénonce on
rappelle pour ceux qui n'auraient pas
suivi décision du gouvernement de ne
plus attribuer les nuances politiques
aux candidats aux municipales dans les
communes de moins de 9000 habitants en
gros les résultats de ces communes ne
serait donc pas prise en compte dans les
résultats nationaux vous le dénoncez
vous aussi je trouve ça un peu bizarre
honnêtement j'ai du mal à comprendre
pourquoi est ce que le gouvernement a
décidé de faire cette build rôle
d'innovation ça va pas aider à la
lisibilité du scrutin les journalistes
s'en plaigne bien évidemment parce que
comment est ce qu'on a collationné
comment est-ce qu'on va et mesurer le
rapport de forces
or je pense quand même la politique a
besoin de clarté mais vous savez on
risque de se retrouver dans le syndrome
dit de l'arroseur arrosé parce que si le
gouvernement ait essayé de faire des
magouilles pour cacher les résultats des
élections municipales des citoyens ne
s'y tromperont pas ils affirmeront
fortement dans chaque ville une vision
très claire de ce qu'il souhaite faire
pour l'avenir merci beaucoup
d'adversaires d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle être candidat indépendant la
mairie de paris tête de liste parisienne
parisien dans le 15e arrondissement
merci à vous merci